[Music]
joining me today is an author the
co-founder and president of
environmental progress org and a
candidate to be the next governor of the
great state of California
Mike Shellenberger welcome to the Rubin
report having me David
I am very jealous of your beard even the
amount of gray I just added up before I
came yeah do the reverse what do they do
it's just for men yeah takes the gray
out exactly you do yeah I'm trying to
the baby boomer votes so you know
Addison gray in yeah yeah I'm very
excited to talk to you because I think
this is going to be a good political
discussion but also we'll get to some
environmental stuff that I wanted to
touch on and a little bit about this
state of California this highly
regulated highly taxed state that we're
in and all kinds of stuff but first you
live in Berkeley I do what the hell is
going really what's going on there it
seems like it's become one you know it
was once the the home for free speech
mm-hm and and real liberalism and it
seems like it's become this sort of
hysterical crazy silencing mob up there
what's happening I mean in some ways
it's funny because it's it's supposed to
be an outlier but in some ways it's
similar of what's happening in the rest
of the country Lauren don't listen to
each other you know it's so striking I
think that the social media gives people
a lot of confidence in their views they
have a lot of information available to
them and so people are just not
listening and I find that everywhere you
know Berkeley is certainly the case
we've been smug for a long time though
we pioneered it but have you seen a
change let's say in the last five or ten
years has something actually changed or
was this all just sort of what's
happening nationally I mean when I when
I sort of changed my views in particular
of nuclear and dealt with some of the
backlash against that that gave me a
different point of view on the broader
kind of culture and the ways in which
people are intolerant I don't want to
hear it but you know just because of my
age I think and I hadn't been associated
with the University I had a think tank
in Oakland lived in Berkeley but I
hadn't really had a lot of interaction
with the students until recently so I
didn't even know about trigger warnings
like until like a couple years ago then
I was like what are those yeah so live
in
we had a think tank in Oakland I'm just
trying to paint for the people that
don't know yeah you know you come from a
lefty area and all that stuff yeah so
before we get into the nuclear stuff
which is really I think your your key
thing yeah tell me that just a little
bit about your history what do I need to
know about you before we get on the meat
here let's see so I'm a gen Xer born
1971 raised you know in that fear of the
Cold War as you probably had you know
saw the day after on television when I
was in whatever 12 you know terrified of
nuclear war my parents were Christian
pacifists but they also divorced I was
kid of divorce
suburban Colorado very left-wing kid you
know at very my parents were pretty
liberal and then I moved to the Bay Area
after college to work with a left-wing
activist group called global exchange so
it was always I've always been sort of a
man of the left and when my views of
nuclear in particular change in the
environment then I sort of was able to
kind of start to get myself permission
to rethink other things and not not
believe everything I thought so to speak
and to start to question some of those
things yeah and that's why I thought
you'd be a perfect guess because what
we're about to talk about now you're
sort of evolution and yeah you're
pushing against and where you get
support it sort of fits a lot of sort of
we're on that and what a lot of what
some of my other guests have dealt with
right so tell me as you woke up to
nuclear like all right so what was the
sort of base environmental thinking when
you just got out of college and we're
working and yeah yeah I mean I had sort
of that sort of basic simplistic you
know kind of lefty view that all of the
problems in the world world do to big
corporations and capitalism and that
that's what was wrong with the
environment and I had this picture I
think that a lot people have still which
is that a more beautiful world would be
solar panels on your roof and electric
car in the driveway and and we wrote
about how to achieve that but the more
we were writing about it the more we
realized the limitations of solar and
wind in particular its energy sources
and we had a bunch of friends who were
just like you know if you're concerned
about climate change and air pollution
why not nuclear and we had to go through
a process really took several years to
sort of finally answer that question and
go yeah we got to have nuclear if we're
gonna deal with climate
so before we fully get there what are
some of the limitations because I think
most people even now even yeah you're
saying this was a couple years ago for
you sure but now most people I think
have that idea if we just all had solar
panels on our roof and if you know if we
had more wind turbines and all that that
everything actually would be okay but
that's actually not what you argue
that's right and it's in and my views
sort of have evolved but I mean the
biggest problem people are aware of is
that you only get electricity out of
wind and solar when the sun is shining
and the wind is blowing and people kind
of go well maybe there the sun is
shining when the winds not blowing in
other way and it's like no that's not
really true either so you always have to
have power plants ready to run at any
minute
usually natural gas because you can fire
them up so quickly in people go what
about batteries batteries are really
expensive just getting enough of them to
store the amount electricity you need I
mean think we had we calculated that if
you took all of the batteries in
California and you stored all of
electricity we'd have like a couple
hours max you know so and that would be
taking all the batteries out of cars and
trucks so it's a lot of it's a lot of
batteries yeah oh these batteries are
terrible for the environment and there's
another problem with renewables which is
that they take a lot of space because
the sunlight and water and wind our
energy diffuse there's just you have to
get a lot of wind to get enough
electricity out of them or you have to
cover a lot of area to get enough
concentrated sunlight to make sufficient
clients electricity you actually have
big land-use impacts and if the whole
point is to save the natural environment
you end up doing things like killing a
lot of desert tortoises in the Mojave
and then you have a big waste problem
that we haven't solved both solar panels
and batteries contain high levels of
toxic waste in fact about two to three
hundred more toxic wastes from the same
amount of energy in solar panels than is
created from nuclear Wow
so when you kind of it's really the big
problems with renewables are actually
environmental problems yeah and it also
tends to make them more expensive them
do you do you think then that there's no
place for them or is there some place
like if you were to derive from from LA
here if we were to drive towards like
Palm Springs there are in the hills you
see plenty of wind turbines yeah
obviously here in LA because of the
amount of sunshine we see plenty of
people with solar panels
Rufe every time I go to Home Depot
there's a little five people that try to
accost me and get me unsure panels and
all that do you think there's any place
for those things oh sure and there's
there's one place for them ISM in my
backyard I have you know I mean I think
that solar was traditionally used for
remote applications so places where you
don't have electrical wire doesn't make
sense to have electrical wire there
solar panels are really cool
technologies I mean just there's nothing
wrong with them I think there's
something wrong when we are subsidizing
the most affluent members of our society
to have and that's what's happened so
California has seen our electricity
prices went up 40 percent at a period
where I'm sure they went up four times
more than they did in the rest of the
country over the last seven years and a
big part of that was we were subsidizing
people to get solar and wind I think if
you're doing some experimental work some
R&D perfectly important role for the
government that's how we got jet
turbines and a lot of the technologies
and our iPhones but when you're kind of
constantly subsidizing them the people
that get punished is working people you
know middle-class people poor people
because their electricity prices go up
and so that that starts to have a
concern that a universal concern whether
you're liberal or conservative or yeah
so I want to get a little more to that
bedroom it's rolling whether that's the
answer will show that for now but I'm
very much aware of that because even
right now as I've looked into it a
little bit you know I see that a lot of
subsidies have actually run out in
California there's a lot that are
expiring at the end of the year and all
sorts of other stuff and also just by a
function of having this studio I mean
you see all these lights like these
lights they burn hot and they suck a ton
of of electricity so my electricity
bills there are are crazy surprises
something I'm very aware of so Johnny
tell me when you started realizing that
nuclear wasn't the the evil thing that
perhaps it had been portrayed as you
know I I think I I mean I helped to stop
a proposed radioactive waste repository
actually in my late 20s but as you got
concerned about climate you started
hearing people talk a little bit more
about it I think my views were probably
softening even before I became directly
focused on it but then it was really a
couple of friends one of them was
Stewart Brand who was sort of the
original hippie you know Whole Earth
Catalog advisor to Governor Brown in the
70s he
wrote a famous essay in 2005 and in a
book in 2009 and by the time I read the
book in 2009 I was pretty persuaded
because he just went through all the
evidence you know the accidents really
were not what people think they are the
waste is actually the best kind of waste
because there's hardly any of it it's
easy to manage never hurts anybody what
do they do with the waste because I
think that yeah that's what we usually
think of our I of the nuclear power
plant in the Simpsons and the three is
more damage for your argument though
yeah yeah yeah the first thing you learn
is you go await the waste isn't green
and liquid because it was in the
Simpsons which is how I got my
information um yeah mr. burns was
running for governor which oh yeah a
little bit more money than I got you
know being right now what we do with it
is fine I think we take it you take the
spent fuel you take the fuel rods out of
the nuclear reactor you cool them in
water for a few years and then we put
them in dry cask storage right there on
the site where the plant is from an
environmental point of view that's like
exactly what you'd want I mean if you
when you grow up kind of learning about
the environment the first thing you
learn is that waste always has to go
somewhere right it doesn't disappear and
you have to be responsible for taking
care of the waste products from our
consumption
so that's nuclear is like the only way
that we make electricity that does that
right now we don't have any protections
that solar panels won't just go into
landfills and leach toxic chemicals or
be sent to Bangladesh to be torn apart
by kids and slums only nuclear really
cares for its waste and it's all in a
really clinical way we put them in these
big casts and and they're right there on
basically a couple of basketball courts
at a given plant and we kind of look at
them and store them and watch on a pill
go what if they leak or something there
in these hugely thick cast but even if
they were you would be able to see it
and observe it and there's not really
anything to leak because there's no way
is there any evidence that something
could really go awry with that as you're
laying it out is something that's pretty
safe no there's no evidence that waste
from nuclear energy production has had
any of those problems who will say pool
point to problems with the waste that
came out of weapons production but that
that is a very different process you're
just creating huge amounts of plutonium
having a cheery neum for bombs and when
we were really when you had really big
problems even there it was like in the
middle of World War two
where you're just throwing bodies and
machines to fight this war so it's got
an incredibly good track record I mean
people will talk about wanting to bury
it under the desert in Nevada and I'm
always like I don't know why like why do
you need to do that like just it's fine
where it is you just store it and
maintain it it takes up no space it
doesn't pose any harm for me I'm like
that's like the one of the Chiefs
selling points of nuclear is the way it
manages this waste yeah so when they
talk about that you know burying it in
the desert somewhere on Iran or whatever
are they talking more about the
weapons-grade way no they're talking
about the nuclear energy waste and I try
to figure it out because I'm like a bit
of a newcomer to it I didn't you know
I'm just I'm I ask people in the
industry why do you need to do that and
they kind of go well because it's better
because it's better look who made a lot
of money building that big hole in
Nevada you know being from a libertarian
point of view you kind of go there's
just there was a lot of money to be made
on these fears that were manufactured
and that were used to manipulate people
like us a group in the 70s so you would
think that there's some relationship
between like a bomb going off and the
waste and there's just nothing the waste
can't be used in that way so I have to
say it's one of the things I find most
frustrating and baffling you know is it
also one of those things that you really
and this is why I want to tag on the
show to really unpack this stuff you
really have to have some basic
understanding of how this all works so
when you even mentioned before that the
the different ways between weapons-grade
yeah and just you know civilian use for
power I don't think people have any
sense that these are different things
right they don't and the funny thing is
so I'm working on a I've got a book that
I'm gonna I'm doing on the history of
nuclear and one of the surprising things
is that ordinary folks knew that there
was a big difference between nuclear
weapons and nuclear power plants from
like the mid 50's to like the mid 70s
like people kind of in fact the whole
people were actually excited about
nuclear power like they were like this
is great you mean like this thing that's
really terrible and frightening actually
has this really positive side and I was
like yeah well let's get some of that
positive side going
cuz all we hear about is a negative
stuff this makes sense I was born in 76
so right when they did probably yeah and
then Three Mile Island accident occurred
and blown way out of proportion but
really importantly China Syndrome this
this anti-nuclear movie in 1979 came out
and that really shaped perceptions and
and that they deliberately and that you
can see what they're dealing constantly
they were trying to mix up the two
things same word yeah you know but you
know it's funny because we have a lot of
dangerous things in our society that we
actually use for positive things we're
even injecting poliovirus into people's
brains to kill cancer particular kind of
cancers you know we obviously immunize
that we inject our children with
dangerous diseases because to protect
them so I think we're capable of having
a more complex understanding of that
technology but there is vested interests
and ideological interests in maintaining
people's fears right so there's sort of
two separate things here there's one is
what the reality is and then there's the
other where when you hear about Three
Mile Island or Chernobyl or any of this
stuff what's the argument that your your
best argument when there's something
that actually is a disaster in the case
of Chernobyl I guess you're saying
three-mile
not as bad as they hyped it up to be
yeah so I mean there's three serious
accidents that involved melted reactors
Three Mile Island Chernobyl and
Fukushima the worst was Chernobyl and
even the worst one killed shockingly few
people basically killed the firefighters
who put out the fire about 50 to date
and you know firefighters died putting
out fires you know so it's not like
unique to nuclear accidents there were
there's about a 1% mortality for the
several thousand people that got thyroid
cancer and then that's it like no
increase in any other cancers so nothing
else nothing else if you would have
asked me just yeah knowing anything
about this I think I probably would have
said oh there's probably like some sort
of even generational thing going no
definitely I think that's I think that's
really the yeah the meme that's out
there that's the one that they even
promoted a lot was that somehow they
were yet exposed to radiation then your
kids would have some problems and we
don't see that and that's great I mean
it's one of those things where everyone
should have been like yay like like yay
we discovered that nobody was
let's celebrate but people were like no
there's got to be something wrong I mean
I think there's also just it is such a
different way of making heat that's what
nuclear plants do they make heat and
then the heats used to make electricity
but there's no smoke and there's no fire
there's no smoke and that's just weird I
mean humans have been around for over
10,000 years and we really evolved and
are in our pre-human ancestors helped to
make us with fire so fire is just a
central part of human stories around the
world and it's a part of our identity I
mean look at the Greek myths and then we
have this completely different way of
making energy and power and fire and I
just think and not fire energy and power
and and we kind of go it's strange and I
think we kind of go there's got to be
something wrong with it and of course
you know you get really close to nuclear
reactors it's really dangerous harmful
and you can die so it's not like it's
harmless but I think people don't
understand you know when you consider
that you know somewhere between 5 and 7
million people will die every year from
just breathing smoke and suffering
respiratory illnesses I think we just
are less scared of smoke then then we
should be here
there's something about nuclear power
and when when you relate it to weapons
in our minds it's become like this thing
where we love disaster movies you know
like all of this stuff so it's sort of
taken a life unto its own in a way yeah
yeah it's such an interesting problem
because my money had people like they
want so much safety from nuclear even
though it like kills like basically
nobody you know compared to like every
other way of making energy I mean
natural gas pipelines explode all the
time oil refiners go down and it's kind
of like come on you know you drive your
car super fast you smoke cigarettes when
you get you when you drink too much you
know yeah we do all these risky
behaviors and somehow we don't want any
risky behavior from this one I think it
is that Association you think something
horribly could go wrong even though
we've seen horrible things go wrong with
nuclear accidents and it doesn't harm
our Laney buddy so you know I think it's
about a lot of different things you know
I also it was interesting I saw you I
was watching one of your earlier
conversations where one of your guests
talked about the infantilization of the
public you know me here we're rich and
comfortable and where we want like high
levels of safety I think the other thing
that happens as we've become developed
civilization is that our fantasies of
what could go wrong get even more crazy
right like you know I mean just the
crazy things that people thought about
with genetically modified foods you know
these just kind of scenarios that we
concoct it's different from what it was
100 years ago I mean when you're trying
to deal with a cholera epidemic or a
polio epidemic you're not you don't need
to fantasize about horrible things going
wrong you're watching them happen yeah
it's interesting I'm not gonna remember
this story totally correctly so I have a
feeling you'll be able to clean it up
but I grew up in Long Island and there
was a power plant the either that was
coming or that they wanted to movers
like Indian Point does that sound right
as sure um yeah in Shoreham they were
they wanted to build the Shoreham one
they did finish the Indian point one
okay so yeah I remember just around that
all that I think I was maybe around 12
or something yeah and I remember hearing
about it all the time and that's when
the phrase NIMBY got in my head you know
not in my backyard yeah just this
endless hysteria that people were
talking about that you know we're all
gonna have you know tumors growing out
of our head and all this craziness and
yeah I guess you're saying there's no
evidence for any of that no and you know
it's always like those panics that occur
and I think you have to consider it as a
panic it's always about something else
you know there's something going on in
the society I mean the people that it's
not everybody that was equally afraid of
nuclear plants right it's a particular
people that have particular views of the
world and there are suspicious of the
government suspicious of corporations
and the system suspicious of modern life
and so they're the ones who are more
prone to have those kinds of fears I
think we see something different on the
conservative side the political right
they have different fears you know that
and if they express themselves
differently yeah so okay so when you
start having this sort of wake up to
nuclear and you're in this pretty lefty
field in the geographic places that yeah
and what kind of pushback did you get Oh
a lot I mean a lot I mean and it's and
it's continued although I have to say
it's gotten a lot better I mean we saw
one of the big environmental online
magazines just came out with a long
article in support of nuclear the I was
in a documentary film that came out of
2013 so it's been now you know five
years almost and that's how long these
things take for people to kind of calm
down and
the evidence and you just get up every
morning and you continue to advocate and
and people you know facts still matter
you know I mean do they matter yeah I
think they do I mean I think it I think
you still need time there's a way in
which like facts matter more than ever
because there's so much opinion out
there everyone's got an opinion but you
know real facts you kind of go look it's
the World Health Organization like do
you think there's a conspiracy involving
thousands of scientists to cover up some
deaths that occurred I mean it just
doesn't really make sense for most
people there's a lot of easily a lot of
conspiracy theorists and crazy ideas but
I think that a lot of people have come
around on the issue yeah so a lot of my
former guests have been progressives
that have sort of had a kind of
awakening and then they end up being
hated by the very people they were with
were you getting that like oh yeah I'm
sure you were getting pushback on the
intellectual ideas just I just want to
sort of understand because I think my
legs are attuned to this when you start
doing something a little bit different I
just want to understand sort of the
level of hate and push back you're
getting yeah it's hard I mean you know
you get a lot of I mean you support to
remind yourself that sort of not about
you you know because you take it
personally yeah you're like well I'm not
that kind of a person you know and
there's like oh they're just projecting
stuff onto you you know the most painful
stuff was when I had a friend on my
Facebook page accused me of being on the
take from the nuclear industry and I was
just kind of like look dude the
friendship is like over you know it was
like that's but I and he apologized
later but it was an interesting
interaction because it was kind of like
hey man you really kind of let yourself
forget who your friend was you know in
this kind of you knows in the midst of
all the Bernie Sanders stuff or Bernie
was attacking nuclear and he was a big
Bernie guy and I just remember being
like you don't you're just caught up in
something and and actually you need to
kind of take us take a minute and get
control and think about what you're
saying and who you're saying it to yeah
and he apologized for it but I was kind
of like how do you do that at like a
mass level where you kind of go hey
everybody can we just you know deep
breath yeah take a deep breath I mean
yeah I love hearing that personal side
of it because I think so many people are
going through that not necessarily with
with nuclear power like you're going
through it but just with whatever their
own political evolution is so let's talk
about Bernie in this for a little bit
because yeah
he was campaigning against this now if
this if the science is as clean as what
you're saying is then why wouldn't the
progressive you know lefty guy who's
always talking about he's talking about
and what does he say an environmental
revolution right he wants a social
revolution and any yeah political
revolution in environmental he wants
environmental justice I don't even know
what that means
but why wouldn't he be free that that's
a very interesting question and I
suspect there's a lot of different
reasons I mean some of it is he's an old
guy you know it's very hard for old
people to change it was hard for me to
change my mind about nuclear and I was
in my leg like late 30s you know early
40s and again you have to overcome a
whole bunch of associations you know
there's basically a picture a lot of
what gets called environmentalism
doesn't have any do with the environment
it has more to do with the kind of
society you want and so the idea would
be we should have decentralized food and
energy production you know we're all
gonna have our own little chicken coop
and our own little garden you're part of
it my chicks aren't laying yet they're
like 18 weeks right now yeah yeah you
know I can yeah I mean we you know we
have a little guard in the back and like
the amount of money and labor we put
into that garden I'm like each tomato is
like 500 dollars you know so you know
it's a bit of that fantasy I mean I you
know I love work in the garden right
like it's great to work in the garden
it's great to have fresh eggs and you
know and and for people that can afford
it and you might want it it might be
cool to have solar panels for a variety
of different reasons I think that when
you kind of get too caught up in that
and you start to think that I'm gonna
produce all my food that way you know
we're Alma proves all my energy that way
you've really started to lose touch with
kind of a basic understanding of how you
know materials and energy and society
works and you're letting that desire for
a fantasy to take over so that's kind of
what we come up against I think that's
worry if you can kind of get people out
of their own life and their own like how
they want to live in their backyard
- well how are we gonna you know there's
like 7 billion people on earth so how
are we going to provide food and
resources for everybody that helps to
recontextualize things yeah so what's
the connection there between what's the
disconnect I should say between sort of
progressivism
and using nuclear power because what
you're saying is this can bring more
energy to people at a lower cost and a
lot of the other things that we're using
at a state at a safer level and yet it
seems to me that even though yes
Bernie's an old guy it seems like this
is something he should should have come
around on so I'm still missing that
disconnect maybe maybe we just don't
know yeah there's something about the
way the left is with environmentalism
that's so connected now to solar yeah
and so and wind and stuff like that well
and it's funny cuz it all actually
happened here in California and you can
see the difference between our current
Governor Jerry Brown and his dad his dad
was governor and he was what the he was
the Democratic Party that I kind of was
raised on sick kids the party of the
people you know it was a party for the
working man the working family everyone
gets a high wage he built highways
agriculture factories the 60s occur his
son gets elected Jerry for the first
time 1974 takes power 1975 any any and
he says he's interviewed by William F
Buckley actually he says we all have to
do with less we need to have less
material consumption we have to obey
limits well as a striking thing to be to
hear from not just who he was as a
Democrat as someone that was up for
everybody prospering but it was also
he's one of the wealthiest families in
California they owned a huge oil
monopoly from the Indonesian military
dictatorship so who was the one who were
the people that were promoting this idea
of doing with less it was the wealthiest
members of our society it was often kids
that inherited you know family wealth
they had land and so one of the most
surprising things ran for governor as I
learned more about the state is our
housing crisis is a direct consequence
of that same worldview that took over
left liberal politics in the 70s before
that the idea was there should be
abundant housing people should be able
to buy a home and home ownership was
really very progressive right because
homeowners have so much wealth in their
homes and progressives wanted to promote
that well Jerry Brown gets in and his
anti development you know so-called
environmentalists get in there and they
seek to restrict homes housing
and energy and it was a almost like it
was like almost like a opposite of what
came before it so you're telling me that
first term Jerry Brown is the guy I have
to blame for the mortgage that I'm gonna
be paying for the rest of my life on
this thing yeah I mean and really the I
mean he's now it sort of four terms and
he leaves office at the end of this year
and all right at the beginning of next
year I should say and yeah I mean and
it's again you kind of go well then why
did Jer why was Jerry like that I mean
that's where in my book I kind of you
kind of are like searching for it and I
think you just kind of get to a backlash
against basic progressive and liberalism
I mean that's the funny thing you get
there's a backlash against making
prosperity for all they didn't want
everybody to have prosperity they wanted
to really kick away the ladder and kind
of protect all of it for themselves
right so it's so interesting so you're
saying basically in 75 he's going well
we're gonna have to deal with less but
he didn't really mean we he meant know
because I'm in his oil guys and
obviously yeah the guys had a lot of
money and power for a long time through
his family because he's he's still
around picking some odd years later now
I want to talk a lot more about what why
you want to be governor yeah but one
other thing have you read that book
right there by a teaching of course oh
yes and I know Alex I had a coffee with
him yeah okay great so so Alex apps
night I had him on it's the the Kate of
the book the case the moral case for
fossil fuels right is the book I hit him
on probably about two years ago mhm I
don't think that I've ever gotten more
heat for an interview uh-huh then I mean
I've had plenty of controversial people
on yeah that I then get lumped in with
and people think I endorse all their
views which obviously yeah in sensical
but I truly think I got the most hate I
ever got this guy on deck is really sick
his basic argument is the title of the
book right he's just saying the most you
can do for humans now is to still use
fossil fuels mhm
I'm can curious where you kind of fall
on that argument I think he gets it half
right I mean my view is that it's very
mighty is very simple in some ways I
mean I think people I think now that I
know more about housing and schools and
other things I'm like oh that's really
complicated stuff but energy I think is
pretty simple so most of us start off in
societies using wood and dung as our
primary energy anything is better than
that including Bernie
Cole right because it's terrible you
breathe the smoke and and it's just the
labor involved right so then you get
electricity from coal and hydroelectric
dams those are the first thing poor
countries get so there's really a moral
case for for coal and hydro if all
you're using is wouldn't done but then I
also think there's a moral case for
using cleaner burning fuels like natural
gas and uranium so it so he wants to I
mean Alex did a good job of this book in
the sense that he wanted to start a
conversation about what are we to stop
poor countries from using fossil fuels
that's really unethical but I think you
should go the other step to say look
there's even if you don't worried about
climate there's air pollution there's
other impacts of fossil energy use and
if we've got this fantastic alternative
and usually we go from coal to natural
gas and then to uranium then we should
keep going you know it's energy
transitions and these energy transitions
which I don't I get too much of my
campaign but these energy a little bit
idea yeah yeah the energy transitions
you know when you go from a horse and
buggy to internal combustion engines and
trains are what drives those transitions
from energy sources so you go from wood
and dung to coal and part because of
trains but also factories and whatnot
and then I think you eventually get to a
electric powered world electric cars
electric heating um as we move towards
nuclear okay so we've hit then solar
we've hit wind let's just do two of the
others you mentioned one of them right
there so let's just talk about natural
gas yes what do we need to know about
natural gas I mean the first thing to
know is that just like on so many of the
things Americans are just the luckiest
people in the world I mean we have so
much oil and gas it's just incredible
like a huge amount of our wealth and
last decade came from this fracking
revolution which of course environmental
supposedly hate although in many ways
they really liked it yeah that was gonna
be my second way to ask you but I really
I'm really asking the same yeah right
yeah yeah so um you know I think there's
two things I think are important to know
about natural gas the first is that it's
just way better than coal like we went
looked at all the scientific
peer-reviewed research and it's just on
every measure water use water pollution
air pollution carbon emissions
everything gas is just better than coal
of course it is right you use in your
kitchen and it's safe
I mean it still explodes
sometimes kilcher want to talk about the
exploding yeah yeah yeah and it's not as
good as uranium which we used for
nuclear
similarly on all the same metrics
uranium performs better so there's a way
in which I just kind of go there's just
this is just basic energy density this
basic physical facts about these fuels
makes their makes a progression exist
wood to coal to oil to natural gas to
uranium I think I think it's important
to know and I think one of the
challenges I often make to my
libertarian friends is that the
government played a very positive role
in all of these energy technologies
maybe with the exception of of coal
although there's a little bit there but
you really oil and gas the US government
has constantly been supporting R&D
nuclear came out of a military weapons
program so I think that you know when
you think about these energy transitions
I think there is a role for government
because there is a public benefit in
terms of moving towards cleaner fuels
and also faster in better transportation
yeah so let's just do fracking 101 yes
sir because every time you say fracking
yeah people think of you know the fire
coming out of their faucet yeah yeah
they think of to make another Simpsons
reference they think of Burns's slant
oil drilling company they don't destroy
it Springfield
yeah yeah is that what fracking you know
the funny thing is the the sort of
famous fire the famous water faucet on
fire scene um we now I think we now
think came from a much older natural gas
well not from fracking and and the
fracking itself is just breaking up the
rock the shale rock and allowing the gas
to escape that's not the stuff you would
worry about if you care about the
environment what you worry about is the
disposal of the water and the the
sealing of the of the of the pipes where
the the gas comes out so the things
people tend to worry about or think
about I think you just got tied up with
the word fracking as well which sounds
like a bad word but the funny thing is
like like just like you know coal has
actually gotten cleaner over the years
natural gas has gotten cleaner over the
years oil burning cars everything is
cleaner and better but never as good as
that next cleaner energy source so the
better way to think about it I I think
is that we get caught up in like how do
you get
gasps and whatever you need to have some
protections of the environment on the
public but really the main event is to
move from these dirtier energy sources
to cleaner ones okay so let's talk about
your campaign for governor of a great
state of California you were a lifetime
Democrat and you said your parents were
progressive left these liberals but
you're running as an independent I'm
running as a Democrat oh you are running
it I am it did okay when I announced
that some resident appendant and I I was
and am frustrated and upset with the
Democratic Party you know I mean I was
raised like this was like the party of
the people yeah that was what my parents
taught me that's what I believed and it
has been completely taken over by
basically landlords and energy companies
and special interests and in California
and things have gotten worse not better
highest poverty rate in the country
highest taxes those two things aren't
supposed to go together exactly if
you're gonna have the highest taxes then
you should have Massachusetts levels of
poverty and if you're gonna have the
highest levels of poverty then you
should have like no tax or anything
right so something's really wrong with
the party and you know I'm a little bit
like going from that scene from the
abyss when Ed Harris takes his ring off
and he like throws it in the toilet
because he's so upset with his marriage
yeah I felt a little bit like that the
Democratic Party was like just you know
and then I kind of fished it out of the
toilet you know put it back on my hand I
was like okay if I'm gonna do this and
just not only do I have to you know
become governor we also have to clean up
the legislature you have to get a
serious reformers in and we got to
reform the Democratic Party because it's
just not responsive to the people any
abyss reference in politics is works for
me good okay
Howard that ship let's just exactly yeah
yeah a lien ship by the way nitrogen the
alien who knows what that wait so okay
so you originally said independent I
guess our frustrations with the
Democrats but yeah you're watching this
understand I'm with you on that yeah
what caused you to shift was that purely
a tactical it's just easy me back to
Democrat yeah I mean it's it's a little
bit like it's probably more
emotional and sort of about just who I
am and just kind of being like not
wanting to give up on this thing that I
believed in you know like I said I think
the Democratic Party up until like 1975
was right on a bunch of stuff it started
getting really crazy after that and
frankly it started becoming kind of the
opposite of what it was supposed to be
particularly in California it became
really an aristocratic party I mean they
we've put in place an almost feudal
system in this state where you have just
a huge number of very wealthy people we
subsidize a small number of lottery
winning poor people who basically work
as the servant class for the rich and
then we drive the middle class people
out of the state and and that is not
what the Democratic Party was about
before 1975 yeah and you truly are not
being hyperbolic about this because just
as someone that bought a house in the
last year that the house prices and you
referenced this earlier about the
housing crisis the house prices are
legitimately insane where I used to live
now I'm in a cheaper area here I don't
want to say exactly where but where I
used to live in West Hollywood to get
literally a one-bedroom one-bathroom
house that wasn't completely dilapidated
was literally a million dollars oh yeah
no I mean look in 2011 when Jerry Brown
took office
over half of Californians could afford a
middle-class home today just 28% can
Millennials in California only 1/4 owned
homes in the rest of the country it's
over 50% so if you're millennial or
renter you work for your salary you're
on the losing side of how California has
got this set up I mean so that's why I'm
running is I the more I learned about
the corruption and really just the
destruction of the California Dream you
know which is which actually precedes
the American Dream you know historically
California dream was opportunity owned a
home great schools beautiful weather we
still have the good weather when there
isn't fire coming yeah so it's like the
state is full of these contradictions
right we say we're the most progressive
state but we have the highest poverty
rate and the highest levels of
inequality you know we say were the land
of opportunity but we won't let people
build homes you know we have this
incredible gift which is this tech
economy Silicon Valley is really driving
economic growth not just in the state
but in the country and arguably around
the world
and yet like we won't let people build
like little apartment buildings or
little little new subdivisions I mean
we've got spectacular natural areas that
we're always going to protect but here's
the most stunning thing the biggest use
of land in the state is cattle ranching
still like a 19th century economic
activity and we won't let people what we
can't let people build a home because of
the cattle we're putting cattle and cows
before middle class people before
millenials but you know you and me Gen
Xers we kind of might build a snake in
there we got our homes at the lot you
know just we got in before they shut the
door finally but Millennials are really
in trouble
unless we can significantly expand
housing so what is the solution in terms
of taxes it seems to me I've only been
in LA for five years I'm only a
homeowner for I've only been in
California for five years I'm only a
homeowner for basically a year yeah
we're taxed at incredibly high levels
yeah obviously I'm not into that and as
you're saying the money that they're
raising doesn't seem to be doing now
things in terms of helping the people
who need it the most doesn't even really
working right how do you fix that and
how do you fix that from inside the
machine that you're saying yeah it's
actually so corrupt well this is the
this was one of the most exciting parts
I mean it's funny because I was so
focused on energy you know and then I
was kinda okay I'm gonna try to deal
with look at California as a whole and
my brains been hurting because there's
so much to learn but you when you get a
broader view of it you what you
understand you have a broader picture
that goes look we need high levels of
economic growth you need high paying
jobs that means that we can't we got to
stop losing good manufacturing jobs to
Texas you know we got to get Toyota to
stay here we got to get you know I mean
really it's about supplying these big
multinationals Boeing and our Apple
making high-value products for the you
know high-value components to those
those products is that purely a tax
break thing like is that purely that
these comes sometimes just investors and
sometimes it's just having housing for
their workers Toyota took 3,000
high-paying executive jobs from
California to Texas because they because
they couldn't afford the housing yeah
the executives were like look in Texas I
can buy a house for much less the median
price humming California is
two-and-a-half times higher than the
national average so just having more
homes makes the state more able to
retain high-paying jobs so these things
are all interconnected in that way so
housing sometimes
infrastructure you know like if Amazon
or a Costco or whatever if they need
some infrastructure built and it's a
good deal we should be doing that and
the reason that we're not is because the
leaders of our state and leaders this
party really don't believe in it they
really are about keeping California
expensive and elite to themselves I mean
it's really a Country Club you know kind
of liberalism it's not it's really a
liberalism so if Jerry Brown was sitting
here and heard you say that what do you
think his counter-argument to that would
he would say that he's been trying to
get housing built but he's just got
these powerful special interests I mean
he says that he does say it directly
says the unions and the
environmentalists are opposed to it now
I've looked closely at this question and
the truth is that most of the labor
unions especially like SEIU or the
teachers unions 17% of teachers can
afford a home in California I mean
that's a scandalous most of the unions
want to see more housing there's three
unions tiny trade unions mechanics
mechanical electrical and plumbing which
are basically working with the
anti-development environmental
organizations to prevent a reform that
would very modest reforms that would
basically prevent frivolous lawsuits
under our very good environmental laws
we have good environmental laws that are
being destroyed by people using them to
block housing projects for reasons that
have nothing to do with the environment
in order that they can manipulate the
projects get their way in a variety of
ways can you give me an example of one
of those yeah I totally can in Berkeley
and I'll give you one for my hometown
the New York Times did a great piece on
it there is a single-family home in
Berkeley that they wanted to on a nice
sized lot they wanted to demolish the
home and put up three homes sort of
switch them vertically and you have a
little driveway that would go in and one
of the neighbors have organized against
it one of the reasons they gave is that
complain that it would cast shade on
their garden and it was like they have a
photo of the garden New York Times and
it's just the most pathetic looking like
I'm sorry like that was like that I
don't even think those plants are alive
you know and like they're like oh we use
it to produce food for ourselves I was
like if that were true you'd all be
starving to death
you know stuff like that you know
there's sort of a question is it is it
economically rational
in other words if you allow another
house to get built will your property
value decline I just don't think there's
any supposedly you if you have more
supply the prices would go down but
there's just so much pent-up demand for
housing I don't even think that's the
case so it's a lot of that petty stuff
the unions use it a lot to to in to get
high wage project labor agreements I'm
in favor of high wages especially if you
have such high housing prices but but
fundamentally you need a lot more
housing and we need at least twice as
much housing built annually than we're
building just to keep pace with demands
yeah is there some argument though for
that for that family that doesn't want
the shade in their backyard even if the
garden is nothing or whatever yeah like
I can think to here yeah in LA you know
in the Playa Vista area that's where
YouTube and Google is and it was pretty
much nothing there then they put up all
of this now what is insanely expensive I
mean I'm talking two or three million
dollars for a townhome not even from my
own home with virtually no property
right but that it seems to me there's
some argument for the people that did
live there for 30 years that don't want
all of this monstrous stuff around them
my slope and I say someone that doesn't
want the government to mitigate all of
them yeah you know and I guess look at
the end of the day they might get bought
out at a really nice rate right so
that's yeah so that would be good yeah I
mean my the slogan that were we're
playing with his give change a chance
you know I mean here you live in a city
okay you know you're living in a city
near mass transit I mean you're in an
industrial you know heavy you know your
home has increased in value dramatically
and then you kind of go we'll no no one
can make any change in my neighborhood I
mean I just think everybody is needs to
be more reasonable I mean my basic view
is like there needs to be more housing
everywhere in the cities in the suburbs
protect our national areas they're fine
like there's so much land in the state
plenty of land in the cities in the
suburbs everyone just needs to be a bit
more give a little bit more be a little
bit more reasonable you know in the
reforms that I'm talking about are
things were don't allow multiple
lawsuits against one project you know
and make sure that you have to identify
yourself right now you can sue
anonymously you know if you're gonna
like if you're going to try to stop an
important project to house these really
valuable workers I mean here we've
brought people from all
in the country all around the world who
are these talented technology
programmers and marketing cat people or
whatever and then we say to them oh you
have to pay four thousand dollars a
month for a one-bedroom you know and if
they want to buy a home we say you're
out of luck
you know I it's just that's not what the
California Dream was about it wasn't
about I got mine and now forget
everybody else the California Dream was
expansive it was it was said hey you
know this is a an amazing state in you
know the greatest state in the greatest
country in the world we got to be more
open so I sense basically you want lower
taxes basically right which is that's
gonna put you at some odds with the
Democrats yeah I mean I mean on the
taxes let's talk about taxes yes I mean
the first thing you have to understand
is that like there's sort of like what
would I do if I could start with a blank
piece of paper you know and then there's
like okay if you become when you become
governor you're immediately negotiating
with all these different interests and
by interest I don't mean just even
organized interest groups I just mean
like homeowners we're kind of like you
know don't want to change so there's a
very famous law in California probably
no prop 13 passed in 1978 and it
restricts how much taxes can go up on a
home so if you bought a home for a half
a million dollars and it increased to a
million dollars in say five years you
would only get only they can only
increase your taxes 2% a year and and
you know the reason given is sort of a
sound sensible which is that you don't
want the like you know someone for no
fault of their own something their house
is worth a lot and and then something
there being at the tax will they can't
afford right so you basically even
though you've had a great investment you
say yeah I can't even afford your
investment yeah yeah so I think that
again I think it just needs to be some
reasonableness so it's considered the
third rail of California politics to
even suggest reforming prop their team
but I think we do need to reform it and
part of the reason is that our current
taxes are so lopsided with the highest
sales tax in the country the highest
income taxes on the top earners and you
might go well that's progressive because
they have more money but the problem is
is that every time the economy goes into
recession we're just in massive debt
right so the when and then when we have
a surplus like we had this year it's
because the stock market's been going
crazy so when the 1% so it's kind of
funny the people that are like we got to
tax some 1% more
that we've made the entire economy all
of our schools you know all of these
government service is completely
dependent on the fortunes of the stock
market so we're a state founded on boom
and bust the gold rush yeah but we gotta
get more stability in those finances so
I think there's just gotta be I think
these things like housing reform I think
it has to be done as a whole and I think
similarly the tax and budget reform has
to be done as a whole because I think
everybody it's a classic prisoner's
dilemma right where it's like well I'm
not gonna I don't give anything you know
I'm not staying to stay strong cuz you
know make them get first so everyone's
gonna have to be I'm sorry I can't make
my slogan be a little bit more
reasonable but I think you gotta get
mean that's what you're supposed to do
as governor race is to bring your way
the table kind of go look everyone's
gonna need to make some compromises and
I don't think they're that big I mean
when you fly over I mean certainly LA
the Bay Area it's just a lot of
single-family homes like everywhere and
you're kind of like look you're right in
the middle of the city you know you got
to allow like a four or five-story
building to go up and similarly you see
a lot of lawsuits to block like
additional homes in the suburbs by the
people that just had their homes built
in the suburbs you know right it's
always like oh yeah the last guy up the
ladder is the one that's like most
fiercely kicking it away right well West
Hollywood that I mentioned before they
put a moratorium they were building all
these sort of what they were kind of
calling like these McMansions you know
these very modern writing tall things
and then they were basically dotting the
neighborhood's thus causing shade and
everyone else's so yeah they actually
stopped them from doing it for a while I
think I think it just expired yeah so I
mean you kind of go look you know you
won the lottery you if you bought a home
in California any time in the last you
know 30 years era you know even like you
pricing your prices even go up just only
last year look you done really well like
you've made a you've like often mail
yeah I mean if you bought your home in
like 2010 let's say you know or or if
you bought it in 2000 or 1990 or 1980
you've made a big chunk of money on your
home so then then to then turn around
and say well no my taxes shouldn't go up
at all is just unreasonable it's like
you you know that's just not fair to
everybody else who comes in later and
they show you in my home I bought my
home I pay ten times more
taxes on my home then the people that
owned it prior you know I'm not saying
that I shouldn't pay a little bit more
in taxes coming a little bit later and
you know and maybe a higher income but
ten times you know best that's the part
where it's kind of like what is it
exactly gonna be it's like you're gonna
have to negotiate something that's just
a lot more fair than the current
situation yeah well I like that you're
kind of talking about this in a holistic
way because it seems to me that you
definitely still have some progressive
leanings which totally fine but I can
tell you also have some libertarian
leanings yeah and I actually do think
that that's where most people fall which
is why I think that this interesting
center that's developing lately makes
some sense
yeah I mean look the market is
absolutely amazing right and does so
well on so many things it doesn't do
everything you know I don't think I just
think you have to be so extreme you know
it's like like I said like most of the
major technologies and the iPhone came
out of the Defense Department
you know jet turbines which allow us to
do jet travel came out of the military
you know a lot of the technologies that
are making the environment better
electric cars fuel cells these things
are all supported by government R&D when
you're talking about 20 years of
subsidies to industries that are plowing
money into campaign contributions and
the technologies still aren't very good
yeah that's when you have real problems
but it's almost impossible to beat that
machine right I mean that's really what
you're up against right there if you're
gonna really say we got to stop
subsidizing some of this massive stuff
and I suspect Yuri Brown probably gets a
lot of money from those guys and just
yes and and just that the machine itself
yeah as existed for so long that's
really what you're up against well
what's cool is that so when I I sort of
got into this discovering this really
this corruption scandal that I think is
really important but my school their
eyes glaze over hey yeah it involves the
Public Utilities Commission and it looks
like all but I just you know I mean what
I learned about it is I was like well
how do public how do you how do you
solve corruption like there's a history
here so what you discover is that
there's just these natural cycles of
corruption and reform and they've
occurred several times in the 20th
century one of them occurred in the
1920s and 30s and other one occurred in
the 1970s so I was like oh like we're
overdue for another period of reform I
mean that's that's where it's like I
think people kind of go you're up
against this huge machine and it's like
yeah and if you knew how bad if you knew
how corrupt it was like I know you
be all about overthrowing it yeah is
that not though a purely libertarian
argument that it's like we keep going
through these phases then we put in new
laws they gets better a little while
then it gets worse but that the
libertarian argument be all right get
rid of all these laws we're extremely
over regulated here in California get
rid of all of this and let's just see
what the market actually does because we
just simply don't know well you know you
gots for some things I think that makes
sense and for others I don't think it
does so there are natural monopolies
electricity things where you're just
doing a lot of infrastructure that is
very expensive and then you're kind of
like okay so gonna have two electric
companies like stringing up a lucky me
like it's just that's how we got that's
why we regulate electric utilities and
the way we do now some of them have been
privatized but you're still you still
have monopolies for the poles and wires
otherwise it's looks like it's already
really ugly like all the electrical
wires
Carmela's you know like I'll bury those
but but you know it's like oh we're
gonna be a whole second or third set of
electrical wires so the government was
like look just you can have a monopoly
and you can even be a privately owned
company but you can't like price gouge
right so like you're gonna come to us
and go hey I to raise rates and we kind
of go okay so some of its negotiated and
just a little bit Messier is there
corruption definitely you know is it the
stomach some extent is it inevitable I
think it is but you think it's
inevitable meaning that because of the
way the system works they're eventually
even if they're being controlled a
little bit there's still the only game
in town so they can always keep ya back
cheating it out yeah I mean like you
know like Jerry Brown's father
I think achieved amazing things in
California you know the universities the
roads the water systems it was a period
of high growth as well and he benefited
from was there some political corruption
in the sense of doings of giving some
contracts to sure you know what you want
is to make sure it doesn't become you
know proportions like we see in the
developing world you know like I said
how much time in Central Africa or in
Latin America and you're just getting
you to the point where the corruption is
so severe that nothing gets built like
at the end of the day we're just
corruption in Korea we're ice know how
much time the end of the day they get
the thing built you know in other places
if you don't get it built you're like
whoa
so I think we've just gotten to a point
where it's just gotten so excessive in
California the
just the exchange of contributions for
contracts and permits has just got a
little place where it's just obscene and
needs to be fixed and as usual the best
way to fix it is just with sunlight and
transparency I mean you know they all of
these really bad deeds can only occur
behind the cover of darkness and so once
you shine a light on it it tends to take
care of itself unlike is the best
disinfectant it is that has been a theme
around here so just tell me about a
couple of the other issues that you
actually care about that yeah well one
of the ones I'm really excited about is
education and you know what's what I
love about going into an issue that
you're sort of new to I mean my mom's
public school teacher was the public you
know was a teachers union rep and my
sister is an education expert so we
certainly something we've talked about
for a long time but what's the fun to go
back into it is to see it fresh and you
start to see these fights and arguments
between people from a like a from a
different point of view I'm not
participating in them but what was so
striking for us when we looked at the
research was that what's clear is that
we've got the school schedule that makes
everybody unhappy right you go to school
at like 8:00 and then you get at it like
2:30 you know and like all the bad
things as you as you know from our
childhoods occurs with you 2:30 and when
your parents come yeah and then you've
these after those are the best hours
about yes exactly yeah I'm gonna take
them away it's a problem you know I mean
so I think schools have to work for
parents so it should be 9:00 to 5:00
like why is it you have to cobble
together after-school programs and these
things and and that is where like often
kids fall behind I also think the school
year should be longer and I want to be
treated like professionals there's
nothing more demoralizing for teachers
than like bad teachers because that's
what my parents would come home and
complain about bad teachers all the time
so you gotta be able to move out the bad
principals move out the bad teachers
you've got to have a proper professional
school day
yeah wait wait that first part though
that's it that's a big fight you'd be
taking again it is absolutely hell yeah
and they've got a give I mean look the
teachers are unhappy I mean the turnover
rate is just through the roof I mean
like I said 17% of them can't afford to
live here so so I do think teachers that
are performing should be paid better I
think the school should be 9 to 5 I
think the school year should be longer
what we know is that the more time that
kids get instructional time their
performance goes up and our
performance in California has been going
down even though we put 20 billion more
in the schools over the last seven years
and that's what seems to be one of the
places that again libertarian go crazy
with California it's like you keep
pumping money right things but then
every time we test it every time you
look at the numbers and we compare you
state-by-state it's worse it's worse and
it is it's frankly it's a scandal and
the people that suffer the most it's the
usual the poor or african-americans
Latinos performance has been flatline or
even declining and so cuz you know if
you're with your wealthy if you're you
know if you're privileged you can send
your kids to private summer science camp
and stuff like that
so so I would like to see a significant
reform again it has to go with taxes if
you're gonna go year-round is probably
gonna cost more how are we gonna finance
that again you just got to have a
wholesale reform of taxes I think
education what is exciting though is
that a longer school day and a longer
school year means you have more time to
do the instructional on math and science
and reading which kids need to get up to
to snuff but then you also have the time
for their stuff arts you know physical
education we need to do more physical
education and then it allows for the did
I mean here we have a digital technology
revolution happening in this state that
we're leading and the place that it has
not like penetrated at all is like the
schools I mean there's someone on a
laptop use but what you get with the
digital revolution is that you can be a
so-so math lecturer or teacher but the
kids can get it now on Khan Academy or
they can watch TED Talks that people
that do that much better job explaining
it and then the teachers can roam and be
tutors my mom was also a tutor and when
I was a kid one time she tutored me and
she usually tutored like learning
disabled kids and she tutored me I was
like wow I was like I learned so much in
like an hour I was like tutoring works
with all kids and she was like yeah
tutoring works with everybody so you
called flipping the classroom kids get
the lectures from digital devices
Chromebooks or smart phones or just from
TVs and then the teachers can roam and
do tutoring and then that allows that
solves a big problem which is that both
the overachieving kids and the
underachieving kids are being neglected
as teachers try to get the kids in the
middle to pass the tests yeah it's an
interesting concept because there is so
much information accessible at your
fingertips I mean the amount of people
yeah that watch shows like this just
for some information my friend Greg
Gutfeld who's been on the show wrote a
great piece a couple weeks ago about how
it's like all the stuff that you're
supposed to learn in college that
unfortunately now because of the
hysteria colleges that you're not
learning right you can go online and
hear lectures from incredible professors
like George Peterson again and listen to
these guys tell you all of the things
that they're supposed to be telling you
at college and guess what it's YouTube
it's free it's one of the beautiful it's
wonderful
I mean Khan Academy is this beautiful I
my daughter does it on her she has an
iPhone she's 12 which I was reluctant
about but with what with Khan Academy
these beautifully perfect lectures that
are designed that we know that they work
the kids then interact with it you still
need to have a role for people because
you need the interaction you need the
group work between the kids you know the
teachers going around but I mean we are
just massively underperforming as a
country and as a state when it comes to
education we're getting our tails beat
by by my much poor developing countries
like Korea the longer school mmm-hmm I
hear that and I think that only I became
a 12 year old yeah I know so what do you
what do you actually mean by that well I
mean again I think cost is going to be
something we're gonna have to deal with
because it will it will almost certainly
cost more money so you know I'm kind of
like we've got a nine month year now I'd
love to see us get to eleven months you
know some parents still want to take the
kids away for a month or whatever just
like overloading kids with information
because yeah I think we're generally
because of our smart phones and Twitter
and everything we're in an information
overload yes like do you what about the
value of that two-month break that we
had as children well the problem is is
that during that break there's huge
cognitive declines it's very well
documented now that we just kids will
forget a lot of stuff and then you start
the next school year and you review for
the first like several weeks or months
the older stuff the kids that suffer the
most are the less affluent kids
african-american kids Latino kids that
Goo's parents don't send them to science
camp during the summer so but in terms
of overloading the biggest prom with the
overloading is the school day you're
cramming all the stuff in between like
eight and two you know and so sometimes
like somebody will be like well what
about like elementary school like little
kids need to take a nap you know it's
like great take a nap you know it's like
maybe the teachers could take a nap yeah
what about arts and so I think there
should be more
like I'm as a writer I walk a lot I
don't know how I could ever write
anything if I didn't just walk and think
about it so you should be more of there
should be more down time to respect the
fact that our brains get tired and the
kids need some time off and the first
part of the day is gonna be more
productive than the second part of the
day but if you have more time you can
deal with that the other thing is that
I'm gonna eliminate homework and I'm
gonna eliminate school work for teachers
so so get yourself back in your 12 year
old mind no more homework alright all
the homework is done at school okay
because you were losing me a little bit
with homework all right yeah so no
homework and then you know my mom would
come home you know she would come home
from school whatever it was four o'clock
five o'clock make dinner and then she
would go back to work grading papers and
preparing for lessons like in the
evenings when should have been family
time and and I think that what I'd like
to say to teachers is just good luck you
get to leave the work at work you get to
be what everybody else gets to do you go
home from work in your nuts while still
working right you do watch television
watch a movie with your kids and then
the kids too they get to leave the work
at school and so the homework and the
schoolwork the grading the lesson plans
all it gets done at school and is opened
up by having kids are able to get a
personalized digital education with like
the best world world's best lecturers
and teachers online yeah so that's an
interesting way of kind of splitting the
difference okay we're going to extend
this day yeah
which sort of goes against my feeling
about overloading but that we're gonna
build things in which are going to allow
teachers to be able to do some more work
and students to absolutely I mean kid
you know kids used to learn how to draw
like properly right and we have like art
classes but like who knows how to really
just draw right like you look the 19th
century edgy you know you kind of go
that might be one of the things that
gets taught again you know you have some
more time to actually and there's also
like a bunch of stuff now about like you
need that social and emotional
intelligence to perform well in the
business world and you know just to not
be a jerk you know those are things that
can all be taught but you need to have
the time for it this thing of rushing in
45 minutes through math and rushing for
administer reading and history is is
just it's it's based on a you know when
we were farmers you know and when we
thought people were preparing people for
the factories now we know that we're all
so different in how we learn we're at
different levels we can go at different
paces I wasn't very good at math
I was pretty good at reading you know
you can get an education that's really
tailored to you once you have that time
and you have we will open up that that
digital universe that already exists
yeah give me a couple more your major
things so yeah so we went through so we
went through housing we went through
jobs went through schools you know
obviously energy you know cheap reliable
clean energy is essential to be able to
bring back those good manufacturing jobs
there's you know people have the wrong
idea they think oh all the manufacturing
has to go abroad high-tech manufacturing
needs to be here but it needs cheap
energy and it also needs skilled workers
so one of the other reforms that occurs
and it's the relationship between the
jobs and the schools apprenticeship
programs you know young people want to
have mentors they want to have masters
that they apprentice with well so let's
get Boeing and Apple to have supplier
companies here whether it's in Central
Valley or in LA and it should be of a
direct relationship to the high schools
and the community colleges and then we
need the cheap energy so we've got two
nuclear plants they've shut down one of
them through and that's what led to the
corruption scandal they're trying to
shut down the second one they provide
total 40 percent of our clean
electricity in the state I want to get
him start it back up again people worry
about the safety I think it shouldn't be
worried but the other cool thing that's
going on is that they haven't made a lot
of progress in what are called accident
tolerant fuels fuels that if there is a
loss of coolant and there's a risk of
them overheating it would take many
hours and potentially many days before
they overheat so if those fuels those
fuels should be tested in our our we're
innovation central here in California so
we should be testing these innovative
meltdown proof fuels and then really
pioneering their use and their diffusion
throughout the whole or in the whole
country and around the whole world so I
think and then you know there's just so
many other needs for that energy
basically if you have abundant cheap
clean energy then you can desalinate
water this whole water crisis that Los
Angeles and California find themselves
periodically in doesn't need to exist at
all with cheap abundant clean energy you
can recycle the water you can desalinate
the water there should be plenty of
water for the farmers and for people
that live in the cities la should be
green is
do that we have to turn off our water is
is just part of that forced deprivation
and and manufactured scarcity that came
out of an ideological turn you know
against prosperity in the 70s that's
what I want to I think that's the
revolution that we want to think you're
telling me everywhere I go we're in
between the roads going one way or the
other and they have the grass that's not
green anymore yeah because we're saving
water yeah that's actually not necessary
you don't need to do it I mean yeah it
will cost some energy to desalinate and
to recycle but look we greened the whole
desert in California it was deserts and
turn them into farms this you know this
whole area was very arid we have the
technology to produce abundant water and
abundant greenery and we that's in Bund
and greenery is wonderful for a lot of
reasons that keeps the cities cooler it
captures carbon in it you know so
there's just an a makes life more
pleasant but this idea where we all have
to sort of this austerity this forest
sacrifice austerity really starts with
an attack on cheap clean energy and and
in particular under clear yeah anything
I need to know the social stuff with you
I have a sense that but I could probably
figure it out yeah just by everything
else yeah I don't think the government
should decide who gets married I mostly
think that stuff has been a way to just
drive us apart and I mean Trent is Trent
does anything transgender bathrooms is
like one of the big issues facing
California nobody you know I don't even
think the people in North Carolina or
wherever that now know so I think like
you know I I'd like to actually get to a
place where it's like we're talking
about what's the common good and not you
know what affects this interest group or
this you know I just I think that
identity politics is just you know gone
really too far it's made us lose sense
of who we are as a people
yeah well I feel like that might be the
sentence we should end this on because I
have been looking my whole audience
knows I've been looking for somebody
that sounded like a sensible Democrat
that I could you know try to want to
support you know real quick yeah my
former get Zoltan Istvan oh yeah he's
also running for California yeah yeah
sure here is he running why he's a
transhumanist yeah that's technically a
party that can run or is he running as
an independent
yeah well you can what's cool is that we
have what's called an open primary and
so anybody can vote for anybody and so
if you're democrat you can go for
republican and if you're independent
just means
decline to state so yeah so but maybe
you're gonna Dorse me not here we'll
talk about that editor but I have been
looking for a Democrat that I could go
oh that's what Democrats yeah yeah it is
yet you're not ignoring the future and
well no because in some ways you go like
it was the Democrats pre 1975 that
believed in the future the ones after
that said kick away the latter what some
force scarcity and let nobody else come
and enjoy this beautiful paradise that
we have yeah but there's plenty of room
you know this is a this is a state I
want to get back in touch with the
values of abundance and opportunity and
and openness that I think I've been shot
and not and not just by the left either
I think by both sides yeah
well listen it's been a pleasure talking
to you good luck on the campaign and for
more on Mike and his campaign you can go
to Shellenberger org
[Music]
you